nos portes les factures d'électricité
s'apprêtent à grimper mais elles seront
moins salées pour ceux qui comme
Jean-Michel réglent leur consommation du
bout des doigts j'ai choisi les
thermostats intelligents îlots ces
thermostat développé par une filiale
d'Hydro-Québec lance des défis lors des
points de consommation en réduisant le
chauffage il reçoit des remboursements
en argent on va passer à réduire sa
facture de service comme avec Vidéotron
avec belle mais Hydro-Québec aussi c'est
possible si je me rappelle bien j'en ai
11 l'installation des thermostats il eau
varie de 200 à quelques 380 dollars et
nécessite un contrat de 3 ans les
clients vélo ont reçu en moyenne des
crédits de 166 dollars l'hiver dernier
sans compter les économies de 10 à 15%
sur la facture annuelle pour réduction
globale de leur consommation je peux le
baisser ici à partir de mon téléphone
Jean-Michel estime avoir déjà économisé
1000 dollars depuis l'installation où il
y a deux ans c'est là qu'on se rend donc
oh mon Dieu on consomme vraiment plus
que nécessaire parmi les conditions il
faut chauffer la maison avec des
plinthes ou des convecteurs électriques
à l'eau dans les planchers Gilles c'est
plutôt tourné vers un autre programme la
facturation dynamique plus flexible
chauffage avec les éléments chauffants
la pompe qui fait circuler l'eau dans
les planchers passionnés de domotique sa
maison était déjà équipée de système
centralisé pour contrôler sa
consommation
Hydro-Québec la vise lorsque des prix
préférentiels entrant vigueur les
économies de l'hiver dernier l'ont
convaincu donc on voit l'économie ici de
363$ qui est le crédit hivernal ça a
coupé ma facture en deux en moyenne la
facturation dynamique a procuré des
gains plus modestes aux clients de 46 à
55 dollars pour la première fois cet
hiver tous les Québécois peuvent y
souscrire 260
000 foyers l'an dernier Hydro-Québec
compte près de 180 000 adhérents au
début j'étais pas certain mais là c'est
simple durant les défis j'étais
carrément chauffage je l'allume avant je
dois monter d'un ou deux degrés je
l'étais à un chauffage et je repars
après au-delà des économies l'objectif
avouer des gros Québec consiste à
déplacer la consommation hors des heures
de pointe notamment lors des grands
froids c'est là où notre réseau est le
plus sollicité donc l'idée c'est avec
des moyens comme ceux-là de venir
diminuer la pression sur le réseau
pendant une centaine d'heures avec ces
nouvelles modalités la société d'État
croit pouvoir réduire les pointes de 620
MW d'ici 2030 l'équivalent du barrage la
Romaine 2 pour faire face à la demande
pendant ces pointes de consommation là
on doit surdimensionner notre réseau on
doit investir on doit parfois importer
de l'électricité pendant les périodes de
pointe ça se fait donc à un coût bien
entendu c'est de l'électricité qui est
moins verte que la nôtre qui gagne avec
ces programmes îlot et tarification
dynamique les ménages qui ont la
capacité financières techniques de
participer seul bémol ces programmes ne
sont pas pour tout le monde à commencer
par les locataires qui n'ont pas le
pouvoir de modifier ou d'isoler leur
logement il y a toujours près de 40% de
locataires au Québec alors ceux-là ne
sont pas propriétaire de leurs
équipements de chauffage ou des portes
ni des fenêtres ni des murs ils ont peu
sinon pas de possibilités de participer
au programme d'efficacité énergétique
pour ceux qui ont goûté aux récompenses
l'amélioration du rendement devient une
sorte de jeu donc
le tarification dynamique
telle que ce choisi tu peux pas perdre
au final quand on voit le montant total
c'est encore plus intéressant
des moyens d'optimiser le réseau
électrique québécois confrontés à une
demande croissante ici jean-philippeuse
Radio-Canada Montréal